all right now we're
live they probably ended up on the audio
but here we go ladies and
gentlemen welcome
back to your favorite
[Music]
podcast
W
with yeah W wo wo
what's up y'all welcome back to riffin
with
riffle on today's episode we started a
little late but there's a new there's a
new sag deal so that's
exciting you know I talk about my
electric car all the time before I used
to take these trips to San Diego I got
to tell you about my trip and my lucis
and there's a new war zone Call of Duty
air Griffin gaming you can find out
about you know
I game all the time but anyways news and
notes plus all
[Music]
that all right riffin with Griffin and
we're back once again welcome
everybody uh let me put this on do not
disturb so I can keep it plugged in um
hi guys what's going on welcome back to
Griffin with Griffin doing it on my new
computer actually I'm also using Chrome
today I just want to test that out so
we're doing that thanks for catching me
live running late today I'll tell you
why but in the meantime guys make sure
you
subscribe hit that subscribe button
y'all uh hit that twitch follow button
y'all hit that twitch follow uh you know
you could be a subscriber you could be a
YouTube member or you could be a patreon
member if you just want to support the
show I appreciate all all that support
helps
um yeah that's great
so yeah man um I do appreciate that um
oh today you know what I'm I'm going to
put out today because as you know you
know I got a baby on the way and there's
always uh stuff about
Target y'all know how y'all always
talking trash about Target well the
haters
do so if you want to contribute and help
out uh you know you want to you want to
do your part you appreciate me or
whatever it is like that in today's
description of the show our Target
registry is now
[Music]
[Laughter]
available let me make sure I put that in
there so on today's
episode um if you would like
to you know buy something for baby Griff
there's our uh our registry right there
so
um oh wait I can't you know what I gotta
ask Rachel something
first wait I just realiz
um she has she has the because we
haven't really revealed what the name is
going to be yet so and then and I
realized that on the Target registry
there's a there's you know what I I'm
not going to put it so you guys in
livetime I'm not doing this probably
next week I'll do it I'll ask her about
it and see if she wants to do that cuz I
realized in the name of the registry is
like the baby name or type of thing so I
don't know if she wants to do that yet
but yeah we do have a Target registry
just for all the target
haters um so yeah man welcome back to
riffing with Griffin um today's episode
is brought to you by door Dash guys
brought to you by door Dash a great
sponsor of the show ready to deck your
doorsteps with savings order now and
enjoy holid holiday savings with door
Dash use code
rwg holiday to get 50% off up to $10
value when you spend $15 or more at
convenience stores grocery stores or
select retail stores on door Dash that's
code rwg holiday terms apply try it out
you got nothing to lose if you have
never used it use it now get get that
get that $10 value right now man that's
a $10 goes a long ways um in this day
and age so thanks to Door Dash being a
sponsor of the show thanks for everybody
in chat uh the people that are in chat
live I appreciate you guys there yeah
you know what let me make this bigger so
I can see there we
go um so we're back here we're here um
you know I'm gonna take my headphones
off today so I don't need to have the
headphones on when I'm doing my podcast
all the time just when I'm doing the
music and stuff like that or if I'm
listening to something so yeah let's do
it like this so welcome back to riffin
with with Griffin what's going on so we
went to I went to San Diego I was at the
Grand comedy club in es candido San
Diego area shout out to the Adam the
owner of that had a great time this
weekend fun times but listen this is why
I want to get into
this oh I should do my comments and
stuff first but whatever let's just get
into this I'll get into this and then
we'll go to comments so I went so like
before you guys I talked about it for
years I've had like numerous episodes on
the podcast where I talk about I had a
Jaguar ipace you know the Jaguar ipace
great car at the time it's still a great
car but it only goes it only went 271
miles and it wasn't a true 271 miles I
would say that you know I would say it
was probably more like you can go 200
miles really air conditioning all this
kind of stuff that plays a factor into
um electric cars and in that particular
car it really
really
really affected it so I would drive to
San Diego Then you get to San Diego and
Bo a hassle you got to find a charge
place just to drive around a lot make
sure you're okay and then coming home
you got to find a charge and the last
time I did it I drove home and I barely
made it it was a whole hassle I had to
pull off the freeway and then the car
went into like you know um save mode and
I'm driving down the street 5 miles an
hour I made it just made it into
Electrify America uh and my car was at
zero which you're not supposed to do so
just the range anxiety on that so cut to
my new car that I got I got a lucid so I
have a lucid air touring and shout out
to lucid and all the people at Lucid uh
you know at the at the service center
and stuff where I picked up my car and
all that everybody was great and and
Derek and the people that I talk to
they're great so now I'm was excited so
I get Rachel and I say hey she's going
to come with me the owner of the place
had a stay at this nice golf resort uh
in in the area so I you know I get in my
car and I'm thinking okay so right now
the when you first get a lucid you don't
get the max range that that is uh listed
yet you have to drive the car for some
time and then the battery gets better
over time I don't know why it works like
that but it just does so if I do a full
charge on my car right now I get
375 miles that's what it says on the
thing so you do a full charge usually do
like 80% so it'll be like 336 miles or
something like that 80 90% so anyways I
get in a car we drive to San Diego it's
great great drive we get there uh you
know I don't really have to drive around
a lot um but then like the last night we
were there I get in I'm driving to the
show which is like 25 minutes away 25
minutes back you know and then you know
the car says you know I have like 200
something miles left on the car now the
last time I was in that situation was
with my Jag and I didn't make it crazy
because it's not even 200 miles to get
back to LA but it you know all depends
on how fast you're driving and
everything like that so with San Diego I
drive I'm doing my driving and then we
we're going to drive back and I go
should I go charge I go no let's check
it
out I start driving home I use the
highway assist which is like they don't
have the full autonomous driving yet
like the Teslas do which by the way I
don't even think they're really supposed
to have I I don't believe that it's act
that I don't know I think Elon did
something he paid somebody off or got
some kind of special deal but like cuz
the other guy had like a new Tesla so I
had a new Lucy he had a new Tesla and he
was he was driving me into Tesla and he
was showing me the drive like the car
was like stopping at stop signs and and
uh you know making left turns and
switching lanes and the car was doing it
all by himself and I was like I didn't
think that was legal yet really I don't
I don't even know I don't know how Tesla
is able to do that I got to do some
research and look that up and see what's
going on so the other companies are not
really at that level yet they haven't
they they say they're about to put it
out they just haven't so I um so I have
Highway assist which is just like it you
know it goes faster or slower depending
on the cars and it keeps you in the lane
so I turn that on on the drive home it's
like midnight and you know the the car
tells you like oh you have 80 miles no
it'll say you'll have it said what did
it say it said have 60 something miles
left when you get home that's what it's
saying to your destination you know so I
put it on Highway assist I'm driving you
know pretty much to speed limit we're
having a leisurely drive you know and
then what I noticed was that number
started to go up it said you know it was
like 60 then it was like 70 and we made
it all the way home and it said oh you
have 87 miles left on the car so I drove
all the way to San Diego drove around
drove all the way back and still had
like 80 7 miles left on the car to do
whatever the hell I wanted to do with
and I just no anxiety at all so I mean I
just feel like that's where the world
needs to go they need to we need to get
to a point where there's no range
anxiety you could drive anywhere you
want fast charging you
know um you know I see somebody in the
in in the chat talking about a long way
AG go hydrogen cars are the future yeah
I agree I think that there has to be a
different type of low you know low
resources Tech techology I was talking
to another guy I went to a buddy of
mine's birthday party and there was like
a a nerd engineer there and he was
telling me that the lithium batteries
that we're using right now would be
equivalent to if you think about TVs he
said these batteries that we're using
for these electric cars are like if are
like tube televisions but then 4K
plasmas are around the corner so
everybody's all the technology that
they're putting out on these EV cars is
like really not the best technology in
terms of the battery and around the
corner the better batteries are going to
be here but it's going to be too late
because hundreds of thousands of cars
are going to be on the road with these
like you know sort of shitty batteries
and so it's like who knows where it's
going to go you know I mean I think I
think hybrid technology might be the
best like I started to think like yeah
it's like we're talking about uh
electric cars Eevee Eevee Eevee what
about just making gas cars so what about
cars that get you know 80 m a gallon
what about that like where those like
why haven't we is that even possible or
some sort of electric gas technology
where with a little bit of gas and
better batteries we could go you know
1,500 miles in on on one you know charge
one tank I mean that's where they're
going to have to go with it but it was
cool I'm just saying that I didn't have
have any range anxiety I mean so shout
out to the Lucid I mean it's like you
know and I'm not they're not a paid
sponsor or anything like that man I'm
paying an arm and a leg for this car but
I'm just letting you know right now it
is really it's a really nice car
actually if anybody's interested in
getting a lucid I actually do have that
you know what's crazy is they do have
like a referral program you
[Laughter]
know actually I should I should put that
on I'm you know I'm GNA put this on this
episode in the notes you know I'mma put
the notes like so if you're someone cuz
you I think you can get some money off
by by using my code and and then I get I
get points towards a
sweatshirt or some or some nonsense like
that so if you're interested in getting
a lucid or one of I I I do suggest you
go check it out because they got this
SUV that they're coming out with man
that looks dope it's called the gravity
and it is really sweet man
you know you see the gravity and you're
like oh man I wish I would have you know
it's actually cheaper than my car I I I
wish you know I'm like I wish the
gravity was available you know when I
was going to get this man because this
[__] is dope uh wait did I did I oh I
I'm using the wrong email sorry guys
hold up a second let me just get into
this and everybody listening thank you
for listening all you truck drivers all
the people that are just on the road at
work looking looking to listen into
something as um you're just you know
you're just doing your daily routine I
appreciate you guys as well what's going
on here man why isn't this working I
don't know what's going I'm trying to
sign into my stupid account to get this
thing and it's like it won't work you
know oh well I don't know why this isn't
working so I'm not going to worry about
it I'll put it in the I'll put it in the
chats I'll put it in the chat
later
um let's see um what's going on oh let's
go to uh this week's comments so that's
all I had to really say about the
Lucid so you know everybody's always
asking about this you know Bobby Lee and
and uh and uh Steve look you know I'm
gonna get Steve back on the podcast and
maybe Bobby will come I don't know they
just everybody's just busy man you know
it was fun times that was episode 11 of
my podcast was those guys it was great
but you know it just I wanted to do it
more often but just people got busy man
all right so let's see brand Brandy
Thomas
09 said I saw your show in my hometown
es candido last weekend and you killed
it I was the woman with the sisters
worried about when I'm getting married
highlight was seeing Rachel there
absolutely love you guys yeah I brought
Rachel on stage it was kind of cool you
know she was there everybody loved it so
thanks
man um Joseph RZ
7pq said you're the man Eric spelled my
name wrong I like your advice I
appreciate
it
um let's see all right where we at
here
uh all right so poopin shine
span you guys your stupid name man yeah
man people don't seem to understand that
comedy is a great coping mechanism with
all the negativity in the world we need
people like you comedians are like
therapists sometimes keep up the good
work Griff because last week I was just
I just wanted to go into like uh you
know I was on stage with Matt R and then
like this lady you know in the crowd she
goes she goes you know we're we're
taking a break from the hospital she she
she yells out this information so I you
know casually ask like well what do you
do at the hospital you know and she's
like well my kid has cancer so then I
make a joke about her really and of
course it's just idiot upon idiot upon
idiot who is like oh man that's not
funny you know it's like a weird it's a
it actually was a weird response
considering that there's video evidence
of the mother clapping and laughing you
know what I'm saying so that's what I
when I look back on it even this week
when I look back at some of the comments
about it and I think to myself wow like
people really do just want to be
negative or just want to like there's no
Nuance there's no thought process
there's no like hey uh you know let me
think this through no it's just like
initial reaction they would oh I got to
get on the internet and let people know
that I'm a good person you know then
they just look you look dumb you look
dumb okay anyways thanks for
that um and then of course more comments
on my Matt R interview from episode 23
when he wasn't famous this interview is
the
best
H let's see um oh then last week I had
like sound issues so people were
commenting on that let's see big juicy
5371 I absolutely love you man my
favorite comedian well I appreciate that
when you're somebody's favorite anything
that's pretty cool uh Thrift th THS one
thanks for playing Devil's Advocate with
the cancer culture stuff hate when
people blindly believe the alleged
victim victims just because of here say
very dangerous thing to do that can ruin
someone's life I think you I think you
should need hard proof to come out
against someone because if not it ends
up not being true there's still a lot of
damage that has already been done that
can't be taken back yeah you know I mean
the way the guy put that is like I I I
agree I mean I like right now this is
what I don't like I wish it was followup
okay so like for instance you know Jamie
Fox is somebody that like they just
there's there was an article that it it
came out it was on the news press you
know Jamie Fox being accused of whatever
right now all of a sudden you don't hear
any follow-up there's nothing so you put
that out there people read that headline
and people believe what they see they're
like oh well he must he must be guilty
and that's the end of it so they'
they've already put that out there and
tarnished his reputation but we don't
know what happened with that case I
don't know could it could it you know I
mean there are feverless lawsuits you
know this does feel like a cash grab for
some people you know um but anyways
regard you know everything that's
happening with all these lawsuits coming
out you know so then there's never any
followup there's never any like later
article where they were like yeah it
turns out that case was thrown out or
there wasn't enough facts in the case
but no there's just like it's just like
ooh here's something let's try to uh
let's try to get clicks put this out and
then it's like okay move on and then
they never think that there's is there
no responsibility to follow up with
information I think that's what we're
missing in some of these things even on
the even for like I think too for the
victims as well I'm not just saying this
as like people getting blamed of things
they didn't do in their life being
ruined I think for the victims they need
a little bit of like yeah let people
know that we have evidence and and yes
it is okay for you to come out and look
what happened I did this the guy's being
you know prosecuted or whatever is you
know there should be followup for both
sides so I don't
know Monster 0033 said are you and
Rachel worried at all about raising a
child with the way our country is
nowadays have you and Rachel had any
talks about this sort of thing that's
from mon again monster
03033 um yeah you know I do think about
this actually you know I I do think
about I am thinking about the world in a
completely different way now that I have
a kid coming I am thinking about what's
going on in like the you know schools I
do think about religion I do think about
uh you know the the the cancer culture
the wokeness and all all that all the
sort of like you know because you know
me I I feel like I'm a pretty reasonable
guy and I I just want things to make
sense you know make it make sense let's
talk about it but let's not blindly do
stuff like I don't like some of the
things I'm hearing that's going on in
like public schools and stuff like that
so I actually don't know hopefully by
the time my kid is ready for school
it'll be different but yeah it is like I
and and by the way I'm not um I don't I
don't have the Doomsday attitude of this
guy of like our whole country is going
to hell it's like I don't believe that
either that seems very extreme but it is
a fair thing to to to talk about that
there are things that I don't
necessarily like you know even as an
artist man you know I've talked about it
before but it's like what happened to
Artistic integrity man like
storytelling like just it's like all of
this like you know it's like you watch
something and you you feel the diversity
meeting everything you watch and and
it's like diversity with with no common
sense or you know diversity with no
purpose you know diversity with like you
know you go like well why is that person
that looks like that in this situation
it don't make sense like it's like they
think we're stupid or something or that
you know we're going to completely
that's what good storytelling is you get
lost in the story right you watch a
movie and you're supposed to get lost in
it how can you get lost in it when all
you see is like you're like well wait
wait uh you know it's like then what's
the point of casting I remember when I
booked Workaholics so the moment I
booked Workaholics they started looking
for a kid that looked like me why would
they do that I remember the casting
director put out
like it was a so on the casting call it
would be a picture of me and then they
would say to all the agents do you have
kid clients that look like this guy you
know why because that makes sense it
we're trying to tell a make belie story
that I have a kid so they want the kid
to look like me so then when you're
watching it you don't even think about
that because you're just like oh yeah
yeah oh yeah he could be his kid or you
know it just like it helps the story
nowadays they just think like you know
oh uh let's just you know make it
diverse make it anyone you know you know
what I mean so then now it's like my kid
looks like they're from you know China
or something you know and then they
don't realize that our minds go oh well
did he adopt this kid or it's just like
that's what happens it's just
like just have [__] make sense first
tell the story and tell it right
visually
everything every aspect of the story
let's make it make sense that's all we
want you know along with so it's not
just like oh let's just throw some
diversity in no it's like tell tell a
story about a black family you know it
doesn't have to be like well let's tell
a story about a family that just happens
to have a black person in it or oh oh
it's like oh it's all mixed up and it's
like we what we talking about what you
know what are you
doing it's like it's so it's such pander
nonsense and it's it's you know what it
really is too
insulting it's insulting when you watch
this as a as a as a consumer because
you're just like oh man this doesn't
even make sense right it doesn't make
sense just make it make
sense my
God anyways yeah a little little bit of
rambling cuz my mind is like I was on a
podcast before this too look for me on
that podcast you know ninja the gamer he
has a podcast Tyler uh great guy D we
had a nice long hourong talk and then
that's why I'm late doing this one so it
is what it is okay now let's go to our
sponsor everybody I got to get back I
got to pay the bills we got to pay the
bills so I want to thank uh once again
um um door Dash you know our good
buddies over at door Dash are you ready
to deck your doorsteps with
savings from December 1st to the 12th
celebrate the season with 12 days of
deals on door Dash oh that's great 12
days of deals get gifts groceries meals
and more and make holiday Miracles look
easy celebrate with the holiday savings
and deck the doorsteps with door Dash
from you know December 1st to the 12th
so look out for that guys need a little
help help with that holiday season let
do Dash be your destination for holiday
deals special offers and everyday
Miracles look at to save even more as a
dash pass member and I'm a dash pass
member it's great you know I suggest you
do this you can enjoy exclusive offers
and perks all season long you'll get
zero delivery fee and reduced service
fees on all orders too order now and
enjoy holiday savings with door Dash use
code
rwg holiday day to get 50% off up to $10
value when you spend $15 or more at
convenience groceries or select retail
stores on door Dash that's code
rwg
holiday terms apply you could you could
see all that
on the uh the the notes there notes like
the edit of I mean the you know on the
just description part of Griffin with
Griffin so anyways guys um what else is
going on so you guys know that the SAG
deal has been struck so we did it right
um you know I've been talking about the
SAG deal for a while so they had like
yesterday we had to vote to ratify it or
if they didn't we would have struck it
we would have stayed on strike which
would just been a nightmare but it
looked like it was like I believe it was
like 78% of the people voted whoever of
the vote people that voted voted yes I
mean it tells me that I feel like in
three years oh let me get that off the
screen I feel like in three years we're
going to strike again that's what it
feels like to me um I don't know I just
I just I don't know if we all this is
all great so act um so let's see so
here's some of the the things about the
SAG deal that I thought that are like
some key points you know for anybody
that's interested if you're an actor or
you're like you know you've been hearing
about this because it's affected so many
many people but some of the points that
they have in the SAG deal that are great
are the wage increases new streaming
bonuses and limits on self tapes okay
self tapes I I don't know I don't know
if that's going to be one that they're
going to um actually enforce I mean
there was it's like this sag rule in
commercials where you're not they're not
supposed to like they're supposed to pay
you when you improv at a commercial okay
so because that's like writing so if I
if I'm going into a commercial audition
and it's a script and then like I go off
script and I make this super funny and
whatever then like oh that's great and
they maybe they end up using that or
it's like that helps the whatever in the
process they're supposed to pay you I've
never gotten paid for that they never
they just never say the words improv
they always go make it your own make it
your own uh you know the words are fine
but if you want to make it your own so
and I don't know one person that has
ever challenged it in like 20 years
whatever since this rule has been a rule
I don't know one person that has been
like hey man I didn't get paid for
improving because who wants to be that
guy right I kind of feel like the self
taped thing is going to be one of those
too you know I don't think that's going
to be one you're gonna uh people are
gonna fight over but anyways actually to
get a hike in basic wage minimums for a
variety of projects okay well that's
kind of nice uh whatever that it's
actually the minimum is not that High I
mean it's you know for it's a lot you
know you know if it was like 700 a day I
guess you're going to get an increase
um let's see what else were some of the
key points
here the pension got better that's good
I'm older so that's great excuse me AI
protection quite an accomplishment this
article says I think the AI was a smoke
screen but I guess it is going to be
something that's going to be a big deal
later I just think that you
know use your sell your likeness you I
think you should it should you should
own you I I I it seems to me like it's
simple this is my likeness this is my
voice if you want to use it pay me why
is that that I think that's why they
were using that as a smoke screen when
the real issue was the money but anyways
they got a major thing because it says
one major sticking sticking point in
negotiations has been the proliferation
of tech like AI the new contract creates
protections around various scenarios in
which Tech would come into play it's
like they wanted to like take Take You
Know video or scan background artists
and then use them forever without paying
them I mean that just sound doesn't that
just sound
ridiculous um let's see what else did
they I mean there was just a lot of like
you know the the deals with the uh um
you know they got more money from the
um the residuals but I don't know if
that's even going to go into play you
know I just I I just don't know man you
know I I don't know
if the um what do you call it the
um we're going to ever hit these
Milestones I don't know if we're going
to hit them it's like like what the
Riders want it was like 30
million like if the project is a $30
million project that's when they'll be
like okay so now we're going to look at
bonus residuals watch just feel like
Netflix and all these places are going
to be like all right here's
$229,999 to make your project done all
right let's see what this thing says
here about the because my website didn't
give me enough information I thought it
did uh sag deal details
okay all right let's see what we got
here um okay so wage increase 7% basic
minimum increase 3.5 increase you know
in July 2025 back background Act will
see 11% increase oh well that's nice if
you want to be a background actor actors
on the most successful streaming show
will receive a bonus based on a formula
tied to the show's Revenue so that's
what it is right there it's that formula
what is that formula I don't know 75% of
the bonus will go to actors on the top
shows with the remaining 25% distributed
to actors on less successful shows well
that's nice too because maybe you have a
good show but you just don't you're not
getting a lot of viewership but it's a
great show but you still your show still
on the platform so that's good like I
said all the AI restrictions that they
got in there uh outsize compensation
increase for background performers
critical contract Provisions protecting
divver diverse communities oh boy I
don't know what that means increase
funding for residuals and other programs
so it seems like it's a win but we'll
see in like three years CU like in three
years that's when they're going to be
like ah I don't know that's when
everybody's going to be complaining
again so we'll see what's going on with
that all right this is going to be a
short episode so we're going to finish
off with like uh I don't know if you
guys know but I do game air Griffin
gaming on Twitch I'm on there daily air
Griffin gaming and I like to put some of
my videos up on air Griffin gaming on
YouTube but one of the games I love to
play it's one of my favorite games ever
of all it's actually number one all time
you know uh that I that I like to play I
used to love Destiny was used to be my
favorite it used to be Destiny and FIFA
were the F my favorite games to play
ever and then Destiny kind of got weird
and then I started playing these Battle
Royale games and I started playing Call
of Duty and I've never looked back you
know it's so awesome so what happened
recently is today earlier but today the
new war zone map has come out so Call of
Duty uh war zone I believe is it called
war zone 3 is that or is it Call of Duty
Modern Warfare 3 is that what it is yeah
Call of Duty Modern Warfare 3 is out so
this is the nerd section of the podcast
so I don't know if you're interested in
this kind of thing but I am for all the
people that follow by podcast and my
gaming I know you are too but season one
war zone new war zone new war zone map
New Movement new everything and not new
everything and these are the season 1
patch notes Here on riffin with Griffin
so basically the game's out I love the
new map I'm not mad at the new map it
you know it looks great I think it's a
combination of the first map that they
came out with in ver Dan and a little
bit of this new map almaza with a little
bit of spacing of Caldera uh the the the
the leaves in the in the world and and
the cinematography of the map you know
it looks pretty good and so then they
got got like you know so then they got
like the these new weapons and stuff
right so here's the new map and it's
called
yakistan
Yan like some madeup country so this is
the new map and it's pretty extensive
map like it's a pretty big map not going
to lie look at that lots of buildings
and nooks and crannies there's a few
open areas in there but for the most
part I think this is a really good I
think it's a pretty good map I think
they did a pretty good job I mean there
are some like pretty bad Maps like Aika
Island this one of the maps pretty trash
you know and I thought Caldera was trash
I didn't like that map either but this
map I think it's pretty good I think it
it getes a throwback to if you a big fan
of the verdance map this is pretty good
so you know and the game play you know
the game slowed down in war zone 2 it
was very slow but you got used to it
we've been playing it for almost you
know a year and a half whatever it is
and so now they got you know the the
maps back so there's there's new
stuff there's new stuff in this map so
now you could do the zip lines again
there's like zip lines going from
building to building the animation and
Graphics are great on that um you know I
love that there's new buildings look
they said the traits are fewer buildings
Wide Open Fields river access little uh
whatever that is verticality long range
Advantage I mean there's a lot of stuff
man I mean the map looks great you know
I'm not going to be not mad at like this
is these are showing showing you some of
the areas actually I see it okay so they
got like and there's a lot of water
there's a lot of castles there's a lot
of like areas you have to climb there's
like you know these flat areas like good
fighting can go on during all these
things so I love all this stuff all the
cranes and stuff that you could climb on
yeah it's pretty good like I'm not mad
at this map at all so if you've never
play and it's free to play so you can
download war zone and just play it uh
you know I love I love down Town areas
so this is they call it Zur Z zaran City
whatever uh and and then you know I
always like to say one of these
buildings is Griff Tower so Griff Tower
is in the back there you guys go to a
griffin gaming to watch me play but like
the rooftops and Gardens and all this
kind of stuff is great man and then
there's a new go Lo map real simple goog
map the goog is for the people that
don't know is like when you die you get
one chance to come back you go in a
one-on-one match up against someone and
they have these little mini mini mini
maps and you guys whoever wins they get
to they get to you know fly back in to
the to the game so that that's pretty
good but you know the the the thing that
I don't like is and and and the thing is
like I haven't played the
game you know for many many many years
like people that go back to Call of Duty
in the past because all the all the kids
that come into my chat they're always
like ah this is an old map like on the
multiplayer version so you know I don't
to me this is all new but I'm noticing
that like they do now I'm starting to
see that they're repeating a lot of
things so I don't know so you know when
you drop in on a battle royale you get
there's a 100 player count which I think
is pretty nice you know the map size new
map size of your the new map is around
20% smaller than Al mazra oh it's
smaller faster match time at 20 minutes
oh okay so you get you can get more
games in and then they have this thing
called resurgence another great game uh
so we'll see oh wow I the returning Maps
Asik Island vonell I hope that they said
they were going to do the other Maps so
we'll see what's going on with that then
they have some other dumb games but for
the mo now for the most part what I
don't like is these weapons so all these
weapons are trash just FYI they're all
trash they need to work on them they
need to work on the damage profiles with
uh people that are wearing plates and I
think some of the new guns are just
absolutely unusable but one of my key
points that I love about the new game is
that it they didn't just get rid of the
old game they didn't get rid of the old
game so the new
game you know it's still you still have
the guns from the game before which I
think is great because you buy
blueprints you pay for things you know
what I mean like you're paying for stuff
you you know you're buying skins and
then a new game comes out and you're
like wait a minute what happened to my
$30 I paid for this battle pass that you
asking for and so now they're like okay
I hear you we you can you know keep
everything that you had before and we'll
just add new stuff so I do like that um
and then and there's a lot of little
things that they're going to work on but
for the most part I'm about to get on
right now I'm going to get on in like
five minutes but then I also have a
workout because I got to go to my
workout at 6 at 6 got to walk over to
the gym and I do my workout but for the
most part I think this new war zone is
pretty good and I'll be on there um you
guys can uh watch me play war zone for a
little while me and my crew but yeah so
and you know what and to talk about my
workout Journey that's been going great
too guys thanks for asking
um I feel myself stronger like so the
first time I went into to do the
workouts it was like to do like the
situp exercises I really it was really
hard but then the last time I went in I
I was doing the ex and I felt myself
like oh I can really do this now so now
he's increasing the stuff that I'm doing
but I feel stronger I feel better
yesterday I got back on my um uh rowing
machine that I have here I have a hydro
rowing machine so I'm doing the hydro on
my off days and actually I was trying to
get up early and do that like just try
to do it every day even if I'm going to
the workout especially if I'm working
out at night like like right today I
have a a late night like a later in the
evening workout as opposed to getting up
early in the morning so I feel like what
I need to do is like get up early in the
morning get on my rowing machine and
even if I had to go do a workout later
that night so I'm kind of doing like
double cardio and all that kind of stuff
so workouts going good I can feel it in
my face too uh I always lose weight or
gain weight in my face first the hard
part is the midsection but you know it
is what it is I let I let myself go
so I was live I was living my best life
y'all uh living my best life so you know
if you're out there and you you're
trying to get on your workout
journey i' I have it on my Instagram I
I've said this on my Instagram but I'll
say it again here too is that listen man
you know we all want to look good naked
I mean that's initially our goal in the
back of our minds no matter what you're
saying to yourself you know whatever oh
I want to be healthy no no we all think
we want to like be at our most optimal
looking self that's really hard to do
that takes amount of commitment and
effort that it's hard you need to know
how hard that is because what happens is
when you don't achieve that right away
you tend to be like oh well then what's
the point of doing this and you stop
working out I realized for me my workout
right now is about how I feel it's about
my heart health it's about getting my
fluids flowing and so I can you know no
more brain fog and all and all the kind
of things that come with aging and come
with like lack of movement so this
little bit of exercising you can do of
like just even if it's going on a
20-minute walk or or whatever you you
could do for yourself it isn't just
about how your body's going to look so
much as how it's going to make you feel
and that you could that is something
that is achievable and it's achievable
every single day every single day it's
achievable now if you want to go further
than that and you want to like get
muscles and you want to like those kind
of things those are goals that are going
to take a lot more work but know the
difference between the two so you're not
letting yourself down you're not like ah
this is too hard and just remember how
that feels after a good workout how
great you feel or like when you're
sleeping better you know what I mean
it's like all the things that act
exercise and activity are good for and
I'm and I and I'm I'm all about that I'm
on that train right now and I just want
all of you to get on the same train with
me guys so
yeah yeah man that's what we're doing
here let's get my headphones back on
because we're getting to that time right
now we're getting to that time the
Griffin with Griffin end um I am gonna
you know I'm really starting to think
about like how I want to Rebrand the
podcast you know because I think what I
I this is what I think I'm going to do
guys you know for the people that are
still listening other people else that
checked out like what the hell is this
rambling old man doing but I think I'm
going to do like for my main podcast
will be my movie reviews television show
reviews and whatever little
entertainment news that goes with those
shows and things like that and then I'll
have my shorter ranton with riffin when
you know how I like to talk about
different subjects and stuff like that
and I think I will do that for you know
my patreon for my subscribers on you on
Twitch for my YouTube members and those
kind things you know and I'll just maybe
put out one or two of those in the month
on my website at the end of the month
but if you want to see those things live
and that kind of stuff uh you know when
it first comes out you have to be have
to go on that so then I get because I
just I need to Rebrand you know what I
mean and you know I'm getting up on this
is like episode 260 260 episodes man 260
episodes that's a lot so you know I
started doing the podcast I'm at first
cuz it was like oh man you do a podcast
everybody's got a podcast everybody's
podcast blows up and then it just got to
a thing where it was just really too
hard for me personally to get guests and
then Co hit you know and it's like ah
and then that was like f you know when
you think about it co was like five
years ago now like 2019 20 21 22 we're
going on we're going on 24 five years
ago I can't I that's crazy to think
about right and it's just like I haven't
really recovered in a way that I wanted
to and now I'm having baby and I don't
want people coming to my place so it's
like a whole thing and I have to decide
like do I really even want to do this I
enjoy doing my podcast and I enjoy the
people that listen and and hit me up and
and give me uh you know feedback and I
love that but it's like at at a certain
point you just go like what like what am
I doing so I need to find the purpose of
why I'm doing this again and uh you know
make it make it make it bigger and
better you know what I mean
so um
um yeah that's all that's all I have to
say about that guys um you guys are
awesome I appreciate you guys for always
being here being supportive let me find
my music you know if you want to send uh
you know the guys when they want to send
um what do you call it um beats all
those great producers out there so many
awesome producers man that send me like
I have a whole
folder full of just like songs from when
I first started doing the podcast
so shout out to all those people like
there's some really good stuff on here
like remember my guy bugs oh I haven't
man I haven't but I haven't used one of
his songs in a while so let me see let
me see if
I oh
[Music]
man Griffin with Griffin
y'all remember hit the Subscribe
button
[Music]
twitch
patre word is
[Music]
Bor listen to Griff Griffin to San Diego
in my
lucd nothing wrongs with
lucd with my old school
raps bring it
back war zone map
saag did
it we l
it did it
it with the F
fitt anyways
[Music]
y'all thanks for listening to riffin
with
Griffin and I'll see you next
week make sure you move your
feet with that what
SK
see you next
[Music]
week